so let's try and answer the question
what does it mean to be a man in the
2020s to me the answer is I do not care
what does it mean to be a good man same
as it means to be a good person next
what is the role of a man in modern
society I'm gonna do what I'm gonna do
why are there so many infantile men no I
will not stop playing Sonic the Hedgehog
how do you win the respect of other men
that sounds exhausting how do you
impress potential Partners as a man find
someone who likes you for you can you
hike up a mountain without complaining
it's nice to have a hobby I guess so
well done can you defend your home
against an intruder that will rarely
come up to be honest you want to cry and
show emotions do it want to never cry
and never show emotions go for it want
to wear a dress great they want to also
cool want to play Sonic the Hedgehog all
day yes that is correct I'm five percent
trolling here but the point is this is a
nothing discussion we should just focus
on the things that make us individually
healthy and happy
bye for now